in the darkness and driving rain the
injured caver was finally pulled to
safety
protected by an orange tarpaulin
carefully lifted into a mountain rescue
truck
only then did the team allow themselves
to celebrate
mission accomplished
the man an experienced caver in his
forties have been stuck underground
since saturday lunchtime it took a team
of 300 volunteers to rescue him from the
vast cave network
there is a sense of huge relief here
this the end of a mission that's lasted
almost 60 hours deep beneath the earth
here to bring this man out to safety
slowly steadily he began the journey off
the mountain to safety
everybody feeling i think everyone's
pretty happy yeah
yeah it's nice to feel safe
for the teams who've worked night and
day since saturday time to head back to
base
finally able to rest relax and reflect
on a successful rescue
i was sure when the call out started and
i was very worried then would we get him
out alive or would he deteriorate um and
all saturday we were worried most of
yesterday were worried so this is a huge
relief it's been a long long few days
and a lot of people were very tense and
so the moment when that stretcher
appeared at the
entrance door of
top entrance of
the yeah that was that was great
these are the kind of conditions they've
been battling this footage filmed a few
years ago shows the section of the cave
where the man fell
a specialist stretcher that floats on
water was used to carry him part of the
way
teams are prepared for rescues like this
this rehearsal shows the difficulties
faced in the vast cave system
including vertical drops making it
difficult to carry a patient safely on a
stretcher three
two
one
but this is one of the toughest rescue
missions they've ever had to carry out
the longest stretcher carry in british
cave rescue history the algarve fin in
the cave system is in south wales
running under the brecon beacons it's
over 30 miles long and is the deepest in
the uk
the caver went in through the middle
entrance known as [ __ ] door and couldn't
move after falling in this section
in the end rescuers brought him out
through the top entrance a kilometer
further up the hillside
the man has multiple injuries but they
aren't life-threatening his rescuers say
he's coped remarkably and will now get
the treatment he needs
becky johnson sky news in the brecon
beacons